ก็
สวัสดีค่ะพี่อาร์ตี้นะครับน้องเรียม
สวัสดีครับนักเรียน
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนทุกคน
กลับบ้านเจอกันเจอกับพี่อาร์ตี้กับน้อง
เรียมในช่องข้อง CNC  Bolt ไทยนะครับโอเค
อ้าวันนี้มาเรียนภาษาไทยกันโอเคครับ
วันนี้ที่เราเจอกันเป็นวันอะไรคะพี่อ้า
วันนี้ใช่ไหมครับวันนี้วันอาทิตย์ครับ
มันอาทิตย์วันอาทิตย์ในแล้ววันอาทิตย์
นี่วันอาทิตย์
เป็นวันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันนี้วันที่ 24
ครับ
หน้า 24
เดือนอะไรคะพี่วันนี้ใช่ครับๆเดือนนี้
เดือนเมษายนครับ AEC
[เพลง]
จะขออะไรคะมีผช
2565 ครับอ่า
แล้วปีคศราคาปีคศ 2000  22
ครับพี่
กิ๊ฟหน้าตอนนี้ใช่ไหมครับตอนนี้เวลา
เดี๋ยวนะ 13:00 น
13:00 น 40 น
า 13:40 นใช่ครับเป็นตอนกลางวันครับ
[เพลง]
วันนี้แล้ว
Batman ใช่ไหมคะใต้เขาที่แล้วเล่าเรื่อง
BatMan ไป Batman ภาคที่ 1 นะครับ
เดี๋ยววันนี้เราจะมาต่อกัน The  Batman
ภาพของอ๋ออ๋อมันเล่าต่อเล่าต่อจากคราวที่
แล้วใช่ไหมเล่าต่อจากคราวที่แล้วอ่ะเค้า
เจ้าภาค 1 วันนี้ภาค 2 วันนี้นะอ่าน้อ
โอเค Batman ภาค 2 เป็นยังไงบ้างครับอามี
อะไรต่อจากคราวที่แล้วบ้าง
ข่าวที่แล้วตัวตีจำได้
จำได้ว่าคราวที่แล้วเนี่ยเอ่อ
มีการปล่อยปล่อยนักโทษออกมาจากคุก
ใช่มีนักโทษหลายๆคนหนีออกมาหนีออกมาจาก
คุกหลายคนเลยหือ
ขับอันนี้คือโค้กโทษก็นี้ออกมาใช่ไหมคะ
ออกมาจากคุกใช้ครับ
แล้วก็มี
ก็นักโทษ
อันนี้นักโทษที่มีออกมานี่ลูกคนนึงค่ะพี่
อาร์ตี้คนนึงเป็นยังไงค่ะ
แปลก
หน้าแปลกๆหน้าไม่เหมือนคนอื่นหน้าไม่
เหมือนเปียตี้หน้าไม่เหมือนน้องเรียมเหรอ
ครับนะฮะแปลกหน้าแปลกหน้าไม่เหมือนคนอื่น
แปลกยังไงครับ
เค้าจะมีปากเปล่ากับใหญ่ๆนะ
ขอชาลิสขอให้เขาวาดรูปปากใหญ่ๆวาดรูปปาก
เดี๋ยวนะเพื่อตีเคยเห็นเคยเห็นเรียกว่า
ว่าลูกปากเหมือนตัวตลกใช่ไหมตัวตลกคนไทย
เรียกอ่ะตัวตลกซัมโบโซ่มั้ยตัวตลกเออ
เสนอเป็นขอดูเหรียญเรียบตัวตลกจ่ายอ่ะตัว
ตลกโอเคโตตลกตัวนี้ที่ออกมาจากคุกคนเนี้ย
ที่ออกมาทุกคนนี้มีชื่อไหมมีชื่อไหมครับ
ชื่ออะไรครับ
ชื่อค่ะเราเรียกเรียบ
คนนี้ว่า Joker ขอชื่อโจ๊กเกอร์ใช่ไหม
ครับอ่าที่มีออกมาจากคุก
r&k ชื่อโจ๊กเกอร์ครับ
แล้วเปล่าเป็นยิ้มอ้าวาดรูปปากให้เป็น
ยิ้มใช่มะยิ้มตลอดเวลา
แล้วก็ขอบตาจากออกตาสีดำน้าหอ
ชาย Joker ขอบตาสีดำๆขอบตาสีดำเหมือนหมี
แพนด้าไหมฮ่าๆๆเหมือนหมีแพนด้าหน้าตาขอบ
ตาสีดำโอเคแต่ว่าถ้าธาริตติกลิปสติกที่
ปากสีแดงใช่ไหม
ใช่หือ
กเกอร์ 5 ชื่อโจ๊กเกอร์ครับ
ให้แล้วในภาคที่ 2 ก็มีอัยการนะคะพี่
อาร์ตี้
อัยการ 5  I  S คืออะไรครับอัยการเดี๋ยว
นะโอเคที่กำลังดึกอัยการก็คือคือคนที่คน
ที่อยู่ในศาลเวลาที่ตัดสินบอกว่าคนนี้ทำ
ความผิดคนนี้ไม่ผิดอ่ะเป็นอัยการใช่ไหม
ครับ
ได้
มีขอนะที่อาทิตย์สอนได้ครับมีค้อนเป็น
ค้อนไม้เป็นค้อนไม้ใช่ไหมเวลาทุบป๊อกป๊อก
We  Are ฟังฮ่าๆตัดสินไอ้อาการเป็นคนตัด
สิน
ใช่เป็นคนตัดสินถ้าเกิดเขาเคาะก็เราก็บอก
พี่อาร์ตี้เข้าคุกชายอามีความผิดมีความ
ผิดต้องได้รับโทษ
กับ
อ๋อเขาก็จะออกว่าคนนี้เข้าคุกหรือว่าไม่
ต้องเข้าคุกเออ
ครับต้องเข้าคุกอัยการเป็นคนบอกมาใข้
กับๆอัยการคนนี้ชื่อมีชื่อด้วยใช่ไหมครับ
ขอ
ชื่ออาวีเด่นใช่ไหมครับน้าฮาร์วีย์เดนโอ
เค
อาร์มี 2 คะและเราเขาก็เจอ
หน้ามีโจ๊กเกอร์แล้วก็มีนะวีเด้นท์โอเค
อ่านแล้วยังไงต่อครับ
เขา V เด่นเนี่ยเขาเป็นคนดีมากๆอ๋อ
ใช่ครับอัยการต้องเป็นคนดีครับ
ระยะการเป็นคนดีเพราะ
ถ้าก็บอกบอกคนที่ไม่ดี
คนที่ไม่ดีและหลายคนอาจเข้าคุกเข้าคุก
กับ
อาวีเด่นก็เป็นคนดีมากๆ
แล้วหาว edent ก็เจอกับแรงเชลล์ไข่ Arty
เออหาวีเด้นท์กับราเชล
ราเชลเป็นผู้หญิงนะครับอ่ะ
อาราเชลเป็นผู้หญิงกับคาวีเด่นเป็นผู้ชาย
ขอ
ราเชลเนี่ยเป็นเพื่อนกับรูทเมนส์
มาเที่ยวไปเพื่อนกับรู้แซนด์เค
บู๊ทเวรที่เป็นแบทแมนไหมครับ
ใช่ค่ะโอเคมาก
เร็วกับบู๊ทเบนซ์รักกันนะขอราเชลกับ Bruce
wayne รักกันโอเค
ได้เชียวรู้ว่า Bruce  wayne เป็นแบทแมน
ขอ
ราเชลรู้ว่ารู้เส้นเป็นแบทแมนแล้วแล้วแต่
เอ่อราเชลทำยังไงครับเวลาที่รู้ว่า Boots
Men เป็นแบทแมนแล้วยังไง
ก็รอรอให้ Boost  When ไม่เป็นแบทแมนอ๋อ
เราค่อยมาน่ารัก
อาหารเห็นก็เป็น and เป็นแบทแมนมานาน
มาก
ขับ
แล้วในครั้งนี้เลยเชลล์ก็เลยไปคุยคุยคุย
คุยกับหา V เดชส.
พระเที่ยวก็รู้จักครับ we  dance ด้วยอ่ะ
แล้วก็ได้คุยกันครับ
แล้วแนบภาพ 2 นี้และเชลก็ถูกจับตัว
ไปขังไว้น้อ
หาวิเด่นก็ถูกจับตัวไปขามไว้อ๋ออ๋อถูกจับ
ทั้งคู่อ้าวใครมาจับฮาร์วี่เดนต์ไทยมาจับ
ราเชลไปครับ
ๆมาจับไป
มีใครที่เป็นคนไม่ดีอ๋อเอออาเฮียตีตี้รู้
แล้วมีคนที่ไม่ดีที่มีออกมาจากคุกงานที่
ชื่อโจ๊กเกอร์ใช่ไหมครับใช่ Joker ไหม
Joker ปิดจับหาวีเด้นท์แล้วก็จับราเชลไป
ใช่ไหมครับอ๋อใช่ครับอ้าวแล้วโจ๊คเกอร์
จากทวีเด่นกับราเชลไปทำไมครับ
จะไปโจ๊กเกอร์แบบอยากสนุกอยากดูแล้วก็มี
ความสุขขอบีบอ๋อรู้สึก
ควยตี้คิดว่าคิดว่าคนอื่นๆหลุดอ๋อ
แต่โจ๊กเกอร์ Joker อยากจะอยากจะมีความ
สุขที่จับคนอื่นมาใช่ไหมฮือหรือว่าหา
วีเด้นท์ 5v เด่นเป็นคนเป็นคนบอกเป็นคน
ตัดสินเขาไม่เล่นด้วยคนตัดสินให้
โจ๊กเกอร์ก็ไปเข้าคุก
Joker หนีออกมาจากคุกได้ก็เลยมาจับจับหา
วิเด่นบ้าง
ขอ
เหอะ
ครับน่ารัก Joker จับฮาร์วี่เดนต์จับรา
เชลไปแล้วเป็นยังไงอีกครับ
กับฮาร์วี่เดนไปไว้ที่ 1 กับรถจับเชียวไป
ไว้ที่หนึ่งอ๋ออ๋อให้แบบ
Batman เลือกเลือกว่าจะไปช่วยหาวีเด้นท์
หรือว่าช่วยอะไรเชลล์ขอโจ๊กเกอร์จับหา
วีเด้นท์กับราเชลอยู่คนละที่กันไปคนละที่
5  VS ไปทางนี้ราเชลไปทางนี้อ๋อแต่ว่า
Batman เนี่ย Batman อ่าเอ่อโจ๊กเกอร์
น่าจะให้ Batman ไปช่วยให้ Batman เลือก
เลือกว่าจะไปช่วยหาวีเด้นท์เอาวีเด้นท์
หรือจะไปช่วยและเร็วใช่ไหมครับหนอย ka
ต้นนั้นชาว Eden ก็ให้เหรียญ
เหรียญ
อ้าวแปลเสียวเป็นเหรียญอะไรครับ
เปลี่ยนที่เขาเอาไว้เลือก
เลือกว่าจะทำหรือไม่ทำ
เรียนก็จะมีสองด้านใช่ไหมด้านนึงเป็นเอ่อ
ด้าน
ด้านหัวให้มั้ยมีหัวแล้วก็อีกด้านนึงก็จะ
เป็นต้อยใช่มั้ยเป็นเหรียญ
อ่าโอเค
อย่างทั่วไปมี 2 ด้านอาบหน้าที่ 1
สัปดาห์ 3 ไม่เหมือนกันอ๋อ
เย็นอันนี้มี 2 ด้าน
ที่ 1 กับด้านที่ก็เหมือนกันข้อเรียนที่
เหมือนกันสองด้านขอเฮ้ย
ให้และให้ราเทลปายโอเคครับ
ที่นี่ batman
batman ก็เลยไปช่วย
หน้า Batman เรื่อง Man เลือกที่จะไปช่วย
ใครครับ
Batman ไม่รู้ไม่รู้ว่าคนที่จะไปช่วยคือ
ใครแต่ว่า Batman ก็ไปออกไปแล้วไปเจอหา
วีดีเอส
ออกอ๋อ
ใช่ค่ะไปแล้วเจอหาวีเดนแล้วหาวิธีนั้นก็
คุยโทรศัพท์อยู่กับราเชล
ขับคุยโทรศัพท์อยู่สวีเดนก็
แปลคิวแต่งงานขอ
ขอรายผู้แต่งงานอ่าในโทรศัพท์ใช่ไหมโอเค
แป้งไม่ได้อยู่ด้วยกันตอนนี้ไม่ได้อยู่
ด้วยกันแต่โทรศัพท์คุยกันอ่ะแล้วราเชลว่า
ยังไงครับว่าเที่ยวไว้ยังไงก็เที่ยวตอบ
ว่ายังไงเค้า Eden บอกแต่งงานกันแต่งงาน
กันนะอ่ะแล้วราเชลบอกว่ายังไงครับ
และเซลล์กำลังจะพูดกำลังจะพูดว่าโอเคอ๋อ
กำลังจะพูดแต่ยังไม่ได้พูดใช่ไหมยังไม่
ได้พูดจะพูดอยู่แล้วนี่อ้าวแล้วเป็นยังไง
กูเป็นยังไงครับเกิดอะไรขึ้นเกิดอะไรขึ้น
Black
แบทแมนก็ไปช่วยหาวีเด้นท์เขาว่ามีระเบิด
อ๋อมีระเบิด
มีระเบิดอยู่ที่ฮาร์วี่เดนต์
แล้วก็มีระเบิดที่ราเชลด้วย
ใช่อ๋อมาแล้วมันจะระเบิด
พร้อมกันใช่ไหมที่ราเชลก็ระเบิดที่หาวิน
ก็ระเบิดแต่ถ้า Batman เลือกที่จะไปช่วย
ใครเป็นช่วยหา VN ที่ราเชลก็ต้องระเบิด
แต่ถ้าไปช่วยที่พระเชลล์ที่หาวินก็ต้อง
ระเบิด 5 ออแต่ Batman ไปที่ฮาร์วีย์เดน
Batman ไม่ได้ไปที่ราเชล
ใช่ไหมครับแบตรู้
ไม่รู้ว่าฮาร์วี่เดนอยู่ที่นี่อ๋ออ๋อไม่
รู้ว่าใครอยู่ที่ไหน Batman ไม่รู้ทั้ง
คู่เลย
แล้วเจอ
ยิน howie  Day ช่วยหาวิทย์ขาแต่ว่า
ก็ระเบิดระเบิด
ลำหน้าระเบิดพร้อมกัน
กันแต่ที่ 5 มีนั้นหาวีเดน Batman มาช่วย
คัน
555 แต่ที่ราเชลลาเจลไม่มีคนมาช่วย
ใช่ไหมอ๋อโอเคนะเป็นยังไงบ้างครับระเบิด
สวีเดนก็โดนไฟไหม้
โดนไฟไหม้จากระเบิดสีเงิน
ซึ่งหน้า
ค่ะแปรเชลล์
และเชลตายอ๋ออ๋อเพราะว่าไม่มีใครไปช่วย
หรือใช่
แล้วทาวีเด้นท์ก็รู้ว่า rash เอวตายเขา
ว่าเขาเจอเหรียญอ๋ออ๋อไม่เจอเหรียญอยู่ใน
ที่ที่ระเบิดแต่ไม่เจอราเชลเจอเหรียญ
นี้เหรียญครับเหรียญก็โดนระเบิดตู้อ๋อ
หาวิดาสและก็ไม่มี
[เพลง]
คิดว่าราเชลก็ต้องโดนระเบิดเหมือนกับ
เหรียญแต่ละเหรียญเหรียญยังไม่เป็นอะไร
แต่คนตายหรือ
ชาวว่าเหรียญเมื่อก่อนเหรียญมีสองด้านที่
เหนือนกันใช่ไหมคะใช่ครับ
มี 2 ด้านเหมือนกันแต่ตอนนี้เหรียญมีสอง
ด้านที่ไม่เหมือนกันน้อทำไมครับทำไมไม่
เหมือนกันด้านนึงนั่นหนึ่งเป็นเหรียญแล้ว
อีกด้านนึงเป็นยังไงครับ
ด้านหนึ่งโดนระเบิดด้านหนึ่งโดนระเบิดอีก
ด้านหนึ่งเป็นเหรียญเหมือนเดิม
ตอนนี้เหรียญก็ไม่เหมือนกันครับใช่ชาว
Eden ก็โกรธมากอ๋อหาวินก็เลยโกรธกับอ่ะ
จะไปฆ่าคนที่ไม่ดีฆ่าคนที่จับฮาร์วี่เดน
มาฆ่าคนที่จับราเชลมาแล้วทำให้ราเชลโดน
ระเบิดใช่ไหมครับขอหาวินก็เลยโกรธมากใคร
ใครทำแบบนี้ใช่ไหมครับแล้วคราว Eden ทำ
ยังไงครับ
Twin ก็ไปจับ
คนที่ไม่ดีมาแล้วเขาก็ใช้เหรียญเหรียญอัน
นี้นะคะแล้ว
ก็เลือกเลือกเหมือนโยนขึ้นหรือเปล่าแล้ว
ก็เลือกครับเลือกว่าถ้าเกิดด้านนี้จะฆ่า
แต่ถ้าเกิดอีกด้านหนึ่งด้านที่ 2 ว่าจะ
ไม่ฆ่าหนามีทำ
แล้วเขาจัดให้ด้านไหน
อ๋อ
ไม่ดีหลายๆคนมีคนที่ไม่ดีเลยหลายมือถ้า
เราบางคนก็ถูกฆ่าหาไม่เด่นค่ะอ๋อ
[เพลง]
ได้
แล้วได้ภาค 2 นี้ค่ะ
Joker
ก็ไปวางระเบิดไว้ค่ะพี่อาร์ตี้ไปวาง
ระเบิดที่ไหนครับเพราะวางไว้ในเรือ
วางไว้ในเรือว้าว
เดี๋ยวไว้ในเรือกี่ลำครับ
2 รำค่ะวางไว้มีเรือ 2 ลำเค
ในเรือ 2 ลำมีคนอื่นไหมครับ
มีคนอยู่ในเรือด้วย
ก็เป็นเรือลำใหญ่ใช่ไหมมีคนหลายคน
ใช่ไปทั้งสองลำนี้เรือทั้งสองลำนี้มี
ระเบิดทั้งสองหมอลำได้ไหมครับ
ไอ้หางมีระเบิด
[เพลง]
ระเบิด
ทั้ง 2 ลำครับหน้าโจ๊กเกอร์ไม่ดีเลยค่ะพก
เคยชอบว่างแล้วเบิดให้ดีเลย
เอาระเบิดไปใส่ไว้ในเรือ
[เพลง]
ครับได้ค่ะแล้วได้เรือก็จะมีรีโมทนะคะ
อ๋ออ๋อในเรือมีโหมดรีโมทที่เอาไว้กดเพราะ
กดรีโมทแล้วระเบิดก็จะระเบิดใช่ไหมต้องกด
รีโมทอ๋อโอเค
แต่ถ้าเกิดกดรีโมทอันนี้ท่าเรือลำเรือลำ
นี้กดรีโมทกับระเบิด
อ๋อ
โอเคอ่าดู
แล้วท่าเรือลำนี้กดรีโมทเรือลำนี้ก็จะ
ระเบิดออกรีโมทก็จะอยู่คนละลำกันท่ารำนี้
หดลัมนิระเบิดถ้ารามิกสก่อนลำนี้ก็ระเบิด
อ๋ออ๋อสลับกันสำหรับกันโอเค
หาแล้วยังไงต่อครับคนบนเรือจะเลือกอ่ะ
คุณกำเรือก็หาหารีมองอ๋ออ๋อช่วยกันหา
รีโมท
ช่วยกันหารีโมทข้อคิดว่า
จะระเบิดเหลืออีกฝั่งนึงให้ตัวเองไม่ตาย
อ๋อ
แต่ว่าคนที่อยู่บนเรือลำนี้หารีโมทเธอ
นี่หมด
แต่ว่าอาอ้าอ้าวไม่กด
ครับเขายกโหมดทิ่ม
โดนรีโมทพิมพ์อับ
แล้วเรือลำนี้ก็หาหารีโมทเจลเออครับกดไหม
กดมันจะมี
ไม่กดค่ะอ๋ออ๋อไม่กดห้าวโอเคถ้าไม่กดก็
ไม่ระเบิดกับใช่ก็ไม่ระเบิด
ไม่มีใครตากอ๋ออ่าดีครับ
แล้วยังไงต่อครับ Batman ทำยังไง
แล้วในภาพนี้ลืม 2 ได้ว่าโจ๊กก็ก็ยังคิด
นะว่าถ้าเกิดไม่มีใครกด B  Mode ครับเขา
จะไป
เขาจะให้ไปฆ่าคนคนอื่นอีกก็สวัสดีค่าคนใน
ภาคที่ 2 นิยมคือโจ๊กเกอร์เล่นเกมที่จะ
ฆ่าคนเยอะมากๆ
หือใช่อันเนี้ย
เหล้าไม่มี
ได้ครับได้ครับ
ขับแล้วในตอนนี้
Joker ก็ยังไม่โดนจะอ๋ออ๋อยังไม่โดนจับ
ครับ
ยังไม่โดนจับเข้าคุกหรือ
ต่อว่าคาวิเดนตายนะคะหาว nty เหรอครับ
ให้อ่ะเอาคนที่เป็น
อัยการ
Eden
พาเที่ยวก่อนออกมายาว Eden ก็ตายใช่ไหม
ครับ
เราแบทแมนแบทแมนก็เป็นคนที่คนอื่นๆคิดว่า
ไม่ดีคิดว่าเป็นฆ่าคนอื่นที่จริงแล้วเป็น
ฮาร์วี่เดนที่เด็กค่า
แต่ Batman บอกว่าตัวเองตัวเองเป็นคนค่า
อ๋ออ๋อ Batman ยอมรับผิด
อ้ารับผิดยาวีเด่นกิน
แล้วก็ให้คนอื่นๆคิดว่าหาวีเด้นท์เป็นคน
ดีเป็นคนดี
ตลอดไป
ครับภาค 2 จบลงค่ะเฮียจี
ว้าวน่าสงสารเฮียตีสงสาร Batman และ k&k
ก็จบไปแล้วนะครับภาค 2 วันนี้นี้นะครับ 5
เดี๋ยวถ้ามีโอกาสเดี๋ยวคราวหน้านะครับเรา
กลับมาฟังกันเขาหน้ายังจะมี Batman ภาค
ที่ 3 อีกนะ
มี
ยาวมากเทียบที่เรียบอยากเล่า
โอเคถ้ามีโอกาสเดี๋ยวกลับมานะครับอาจจะ
ได้ฟัง Batman ภาคที่ 3 กันนะครับถ้ามี
เวลานะครับหน้าโอเคถ้างั้นวันนี้หมดเวลา
แล้วใช่ไหมครับอ้าถ้างั้นเดี๋ยวเรา
หรือต้องลาไปก่อนแล้วครับวันนี้น่ะสวัสดี
ครับนักเรียน
เช้าสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดีค่ะพี่
อาร์ตี้เลยครับนักเรียนมบ๊ายบาย